(whooshing)
(beeping)
(gentle music)
(bouncy music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brain,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(bouncy music)
(bright music)
(perky music)
- I'm gonna give you a perspective,
a very brief perspective,
on what I think is the topic today
from the vantage point of somebody
who is a clinical neurologist
and a research geneticist.
That's really where I'm coming from.
Hopefully this idea of a continuum
will make sense as I go through.
Two themes that I'd like
to present and discuss,
human disorders of cognition and behavior
are part of normal human variation,
in other words the human condition.
And to understand human brain function
we must understand individual variability.
That's the key.
From a geneticists' standpoint,
this says, for those
of you who can't read,
because my genetic programming prevents me
from stopping to ask
directions, that's why.
Those of you who have been
in that situation before,
you can't blame your spouse.
This is genetic programming.
Of course we know that that's not true,
that behavior is a combination
of genes and the environment.
But genes play a kind of considerable role
in all the behavior, as
I'll discuss really briefly,
as well as brain structure and function,
which is what underlies our behavior.
It's the organ that is
essential for behavior.
Neuropsychiatric disorders
are also highly heritable.
I'm just showing here in a
how prevalent many of these disorders are.
Even the rarest, like Tourette's syndrome,
is close to a percent in the population,
Schizophrenia about a percent,
autism a little more then a percent
all the way up to anxiety,
which is about 30% general.
But if you look at the
calculated heritability,
which is just an estimate
from twin and family studies,
all of these disorders have
very substantial heritability.
On some of them the error
bars are quite large,
but they range.
None of them are less than 40%
and many of them are over 80%.
We really have a group of
highly heritable disorders
and the question is where
does that come from?
Again, as a neuroscientist and neurologist
as well as a geneticist,
genes interact with the
environment during development
to lead to cerebral structure.
Structure is not a static structure.
This is a very highly dynamic structure.
We have what we can see,
what you can see with
imaging or other tools.
You have microscopic anatomy.
But you also have chemical
and molecular plasticity
that's ongoing virtually constantly.
As you're listening to this it's ongoing.
Of course, that is what
underlies cognitive function.
Of course it's not a unidirectional.
Development occurs over time
and cognitive function and behavior
feeds back on brain structure
so there's a constant
iteration of the brain
as we develop and as we're
exposed to the environment.
Of course, as we all look
around we can see each other
and we're all highly variable,
we're all individuals.
We look at each other,
we should be able to tell each other
all apart from each
other most of the time.
The same thing with the brain.
There's an enormous amount
of variability in the brain.
Here is just one example of that
that I found quite interesting
from Laurence Binder.
This is the IQ test,
or it's one of the IQ tests.
Forgive me, I'm not a psychologist
so I'm just presenting this.
This is from a paper that he did
and basically if you go
up to 11 or 14 subtests
on these different domains that make up IQ
and look at the percentage
of people who score,
these are normal people who
score in the abnormal range
on at least one test, it's 71,
and if you go to 14 the more tests 82%
score in the abnormal range.
If you look at three standard deviations,
would be called abnormal in
psychoeducational testing,
it's almost a quarter when
you're doing 14 subtests.
What does that mean?
We all have strengths and weaknesses.
We kind of know that, but
we don't act that way.
Our educational system
doesn't work that way
and a lot of times that we
even discuss our own colleagues
we don't act that way.
(audience laughing)
Here's another point
is that if you look at
functional brain networks,
which are just kind of color coded here,
things that are interconnected
with each other,
no brain area really acts alone,
they're connected in networks.
But if we look at a map of
inter-subject variability,
red being very high,
we can see that the areas
of highest inter-subject variability
are those areas that are
kind of the most multi-modal,
called heteromodal, association cortices.
These are not the regions
that are involved in primary sensation
like vision or touch or motor function,
these are the places where thoughts come
and the environment is integrated.
That's really a critical issue
is that the things, like the
frontal lobe and other circuits
that really make us who
we are, allow us to plan
and really account for a lot
of our uniquely human characteristics,
are the most variable between us.
Of course I mentioned there's
a high degree of variability,
there's also a high
degree of heritability.
This is, again, my genetics viewpoint.
I'm not deterministic,
please don't get that idea,
but there are two twins.
I just find this picture
so unbelievably cute.
(audience laughing)
Much cuter than the identical twin brains.
The point here is that
identical twin brains
are also highly similar,
just like twins look
similar on the outside,
the brain, the structure, the function,
highly, highly similar.
In fact, most structures in the brain,
let's start with the cerebral cortex,
are around 70% to 80% heritability.
This maintains over
the lifespan, actually,
so it's quite interesting.
Then the question is,
I showed you that IQ kind of test
that shows that you might
have a really high IQ,
but the likelihood is
you're gonna be really poor
in a few areas.
Let's explore that a little bit.
Is ability really uni-dimensional?
The concept of g, or general intelligence.
This is highly heritable.
I think its heritability is around .6
and it's related to many
psychoeducational tests.
Again, as a neurologist,
not as a psychologist,
I look at it as things
that task working memory
and frontal lobe function very strongly,
but it doesn't predict many functions.
You can have a very high IQ
and be bad in certain things.
Therefore, again,
just like that Binder
table that I showed you,
we have to be really careful
when we're looking at people
to really understand
strengths and weaknesses,
which I think is one of the themes
of the discussion that
we're gonna have today
talking about very unusual strengths.
Ability is specific.
I'm just gonna hammer
this in a little bit.
This is what I think is a
spectacular chalk drawing
from somebody that I don't know well,
but I've talked to his mother
quite a bit at some times,
who is an autistic artist
named Jonathan Lerman
who is a really remarkable artist.
The foreword to this book
is written by the New
York Times art critic.
This is a serious artist
and I have some of his art
and it's very Picasso-esque.
It's absolutely brilliant.
But there are times when he's
been absolutely non-verbal
and really highly dysfunctional
and having a lot of problems.
This is not that uncommon.
How about me?
I'm a relatively smart guy.
I have a few degrees.
I'm not up there
with the people we're gonna
be talking about today.
I don't have any of those qualities.
I'm kind of not exceptional.
I'm just a professor.
(audience chuckling)
No, seriously.
There's nothing exceptional about that.
And yet at the same time,
I've had to do well in school
and that's because school
involves writing and reading
and mathematics and I can do that.
But this is one thing I can't do,
and this is not a joke.
(audience laughing)
I've been drawing like that
since I was in third or fourth grade.
This is the best I can do.
I'm not joking.
Ability is a combination of
genes and the environment
so there's no question that
I could probably do better
if I put my mind to it.
Bruce Miller believes that I can.
I've tried at times 'cause
my mom was an artist
and she tried to get me to draw and stuff
and I was really, really bad.
Just the point I want to make
is that strengths and weaknesses,
some strengths come together,
they come in groups,
and we're gonna talk
about that a lot today,
but the point is just because
one's strong in one area
doesn't mean that you're
strong in all areas.
If we had an educational system
where I had to represent the world
in two or three dimensions,
I wouldn't have gotten
very far, I'm sure of that.
How does this fit into genetics?
This is from Wikimedia images,
one of my main sources.
We use this a lot.
It's actually probably
from Daniel MacArthur,
it's a cartoon from the Broad group.
What you can see here
is this is 10,000 B.C.
This is around where we are right now.
This is the estimated
population in billions.
You can see that there's an enormous rise
that humans were a very small population.
We essentially have arisen
from an ancestral population
more than 10,000 years ago.
What's interesting
is that we come from a
small set of ancestors
and that means that we share
a common genetic variation
that's been acted on by evolution.
If those had been very deleterious,
anything that's highly
deleterious would get removed
after thousands of generations.
The variation that we all share
that is common genetic variation,
things greater than 1% in the population,
our genomes are 99.9% identical.
Those things that we share
have been acted on by natural selection
to remove strong bad actors.
Therefore the things that contribute
to most of our human phenotypes,
from diabetes to human cognition,
each individually have
very small effect sizes.
So they haven't been purified.
When we're looking for
genes that cause diseases,
a lot of what's going on in
genetic association studies
is we're looking for relatively
high frequency variance
that are more than 1% in the population,
but they have very small effect sizes
as opposed to mutation screens
that identify genes of large effect
but they're generally much rarer.
I'm not saying that all human variation
is due to common variation,
but a good deal of it is.
We can begin to think, and
this is a classic behavior
from a behavior genetics textbook
from DeFries and Robert Plomin,
actually the w doesn't belong there.
There's part of my residual
dyslexia from childhood.
Complex diseases and disorders
and all complex human cognition
lies on a continuum of normal variability,
a disease threshold model
where we get one copy
of each gene from mom
and one from dad and
this particular variant,
if you have the BB variant
you're likely to be passed the threshold
but it's not deterministic.
Think about this as an additive
said of normal distributions
where these variance of
very small effect sizes
are adding, adding, adding up.
Another point is that the
threshold is somewhat arbitrary
in many cases.
What's high blood pressure?
What's high glucose?
What's bad reading?
What's attention deficit
disorder, et cetera.
This is all somewhat
an arbitrary threshold
that's based upon society
and what usually,
hopefully, what's practical
for the biomedical enterprise.
This is the kind of foundation
that took me, when I
started to work on autism
now about 17 years ago,
to think about autism
as part of the continuum
of normal variation.
This is the idea.
Autism diagnosis depends
upon quantitative impairment
in multiple domains.
It's not qualitative.
Some people here are really
good socially, some aren't.
To become autistic you
have to fall out here.
If you think of each of these
as a contour of normal distribution
where the green is highly advantageous,
really superior functioning,
and the red is less than optimal.
Children with autism
have to have repetitive
restrictive behavior
and deficits in social behavior.
The diagnosis has changed
over the last five years
so that language is now not
fundamentally part of it
but it often is.
Just the point here is
that, again, a line is drawn
and you have to have
impairment in multiple domains
that's quantitative and measured
so that those people that are here
who might be a sibling on one area
aren't autistic, of if they're here.
That's arbitrary, again.
It's our diagnosis.
Do we have proof of that?
Yes, there's quite a bit of proof.
I'm gonna show you one
really nice piece of data
that was published recently by
Elise Robinson and Mark Daly.
Social function in those without autism
is strongly related to
the same genetic factors
that increase autism genetic risk.
What you can do is you can come up
with a compositive genetic score,
all these little small
common risk variance,
add them up in what's called
a polygenic risk score.
You can ask if I have that for autism
and it has about a 70% prediction
for who's gonna be autistic,
how well is that correlated
with just autism in the normal population?
And the normal population being used here
is a longitudinal study of
parents and children in Avon,
it's in England, it's called ALSPAC.
If you look, you can see
that the genetic correlation
between the Psychiatric
Genomics Consortium Autism
and a Danish autism consortium
are both close to .3.
That's an enormous correlation.
That's telling us
that the things in the
common variation that we have
that predisposes to autism
is part of normal variation.
How about other things?
You're gonna hear a lot more
about some of these topics today
but I just wanted to touch on them
and give you a point of
view, maybe a framework.
There's something called synaesthesia.
And this is a slide from my
colleague Simon Baron Cohen
who would have given a much
better talk than I am giving
and unfortunately can't be here.
Stimulation of one sensory modality
automatically triggers a
perception in a second.
It might be that when you see a word,
you hear music with it.
Or vice versa.
When you hear music, there's
a color associated with it.
It's actually present in
some degree or another
in 4% of the population.
There's evidence that
it has genetic factors.
About almost 40% have at
least one other family member
with synesthesia and
there's been some evidence
of genetic linkage even, but
no genes have been identified
as far as I'm aware,
but maybe Simon knows or Simon Fisher.
Now I'm gonna tell you just a brief bit
about somebody that Simon
Baron Cohen knows quite well,
which is Daniel Tammet.
Many of you may have read
his book Born on a Blue Day.
If you haven't read it, you must read it.
It is an extraordinary book.
If you haven't read it,
you wouldn't believe that
there's somebody who can do this.
He sees numbers as shapes and colors.
This Test of Genuineness is a test
that is related to synesthesia.
He's invented his own language.
He learns languages in two weeks.
I think he learned Finnish
in two weeks perfectly.
He performs mathematical calculations
that you can't imagine.
He is the European
champion in Pi to 22,515.
And he has Asperger's syndrome.
Okay, that's an interesting observation.
That's a very, rare, unique
individual with these features.
You can ask the question
is synesthesia increased
in people with autism?
If independent, synesthesia
and autism should co-occur
in four out of 10,000 people.
But they're not.
Simon Baron Cohen's study
shows that it's present in almost 19%.
Of course, this is done via questionnaire
so it would have to be
redone measuring it.
I think one would argue
that it's quite enriched.
There's also an enrichment
among those who have perfect
pitch with synesthesia,
in this study about 20%.
There's a relationship
of some of the things
that we're gonna be talking about today
that are really extraordinary
variations on the human mind
and common genetic variation
and what we think of as intellectual
or behavior disabilities or disorders.
I'll leave you with one thought.
What does it mean that a
feature that is present rarely
in the general population
is more frequent in those with a disorder?
Of course it means that
the human condition
is one of strengths and weaknesses
and that great strength can
be the flip side of disability
and in part, this is because
of the genetic contributions
to evolution, to human brain evolution,
that we've inherited strengths
along with weaknesses
and sometimes they lead to
what we call a disorder.
I'm gonna leave you with
another interesting thought
that if you look
at the most variable
brain regions in humans
there are also those
that have expanded most
on the human lineage,
getting back to one of my earliest slides.
Again, this is from a paper
Mueller et al A Neuron in 2013.
Basically if you look at the
cortical surface expansion
in this frontal, parietal,
temporal lobe area
and then you look at the areas
with the most inter-subject
variability, there it is.
We know that cortical surface volume,
especially volume as highly heritabile,
so that this variability is
highly heritabile as well.
You can look at this correlation.
There's a strong correlation throughout,
not just in my picture.
We've had 150 years in
behavioral neurology
of learning from the individual
from Tan, who was Broca's first patient,
and from seeing two patients
he reasoned that language
was in the frontal lobes.
Maybe that was a little too specific.
Wernicke helped him out a little bit.
But he reasoned that the cerebral cortex
was therefore asymmetric and
that language was on one side.
Here's another patient, Patient HM,
who was one of a series of patients
who had bilateral hippocampal damage
and played important roles in
our understanding of memory.
Again, I wanna say that we must learn
to continue to understand the nature
of individual differences
and how disease, what we
call disease and disorders,
is really just part of
the human condition.
These exceptional variations
are often strongly associated
with vulnerabilities.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- It is a pleasure and an honor to be here
and to have the opportunity
to talk with you
about our work integrating
genes, brain, and behavior
in a truly extraordinary human condition
called Williams syndrome.
An important point of
departure for this talk
is the fact that brain
function or disfunction
can be observed at multiple
levels of neuronal organization.
The most basic, of
course, is gene expression
which works through cellular
and brain circuitry mechanisms
to produce the complex emergent phenomena
that make us who and what we are,
conferring complex behaviors,
and, in some cases,
susceptibility to disorders.
There's been a tremendous impetus
in our research portfolios
to understand the genetic determinance
of this cascade of events.
It's really easy to understand
why this is the case
because genes are entry
points to molecular pathways
that can lead us to new treatments,
to early detection and
possibly to prevention
of diseases and teach
us about our variability
and what makes us who and what we are.
I'm going to be telling
you about Williams syndrome
which is a truly extraordinary model
of phenotype, genotype relationships
and that allows us to make inferences
across these multiple levels
of neuronal organization
and sometimes disorganization.
Let me tell you first
about the genetics of Williams syndrome.
This is a rare disorder.
It exists in somewhere
between one in 7,500
and one in 20,000 live births,
depending on whose
statistics one believes.
It is caused by the
removal, the hemi deletion,
of one copy of a number of
genes, about 25 of them,
on chromosome seven in this locale.
This is about 1.6 megabases
of genetic material.
This is a very active part of our genome
and the reason is that this segment of DNA
is flanked on both sides
for everyone in this room
by low copy repeat sequences.
This means that there
are similar DNA sequences
here and here.
It's thought that these
are of recent origin
and rapid evolution that play
a role in hominid speciation.
This causes mistakes during recombination.
These two ends can get mixed up.
This leads to either
the removal of one copy,
which is what causes Williams syndrome,
or duplication, which causes three copies
of genes to be present in this region.
At the end of my talk I'll tell you
about this fascinating
duplication syndrome.
But first about Williams syndrome.
I, and my colleagues, we were
drawn to Williams syndrome
because this is a very well-defined,
circumscribed cognitive behavioral
profile in human beings,
which I'll tell you about in a moment.
Moreover the affected genes are known,
unlike many of the complex
disorders that we study.
Schizophrenia, autism, et cetera,
many of the ones that Doctor
Geschwind showed before.
We hoped that by studying
Williams syndrome,
this gold standard
phenotype, genotype link,
that we would be able to
uncover neurogenetic mechanisms
that underlie complex human
behaviors and disorders.
Our strategy has been to very carefully
define the brain phenotype,
the brain features,
that characterize Williams syndrome
and to use this information
to bridge the knowledge gap
between genes and behavior.
Let me tell you a little
bit about the syndrome.
People with Williams syndrome
have facial features
that are very similar.
This is an old picture, very famous,
from one of Doctor
Bellugi's seminal papers,
and you can see how much
these unrelated children
with Williams syndrome look.
It was really two hallmark
neurobehavioral features
that caught our interest.
One in the domain of personality,
and one in the domain of cognition.
I'll be speaking about each of these.
Let's talk about the
cognitive profile first.
This is a distinctive pattern
of peaks and valleys in abilities.
Language is very good.
Face recognition is preserved.
But visuospatial construction
is markedly impaired.
Visuospatial construction is the ability
to visualize an object or
picture as a set of parts
and construct a replica of
the object from those parts.
This is the classic neuropsychometric test
that's used to access visuospatial
constructive abilities.
This is the block design test.
People are shown a model like this
and they're given some blocks
and asked to reconstruct it.
You can see how poorly folks
with Williams syndrome do
even compared to folks with Downs syndrome
with the same IQs.
Another way that this can
be accessed is by drawing,
which Doctor Geschwind was talking about.
This is a 9 1/2 year old
child drawing a bicycle.
We would not know at all
that this was a bicycle
if the parts weren't labeled for us.
So a dissolution of this
information in space.
I love this example, again,
from a work of Doctor Bellugi's.
This is an elephant and
we would not know that
if this weren't labeled.
This is a pretty impoverished picture
and compare it to this
rather rich depiction
in the verbal domain from the same teen
with Williams syndrome.
I'll read some of it to you.
It lives in the jungle.
It can also live in the zoo.
It has long, great ears, fan ears,
ears that can blow in the wind.
If they're in a bad
mood it can be terrible.
It could stomp, it could charge.
They have big long tusks.
They can damage a car.
You don't want an elephant as a pet.
You want a cat, a dog, or a bird.
(audience laughing)
Pretty rich and very lyrical, almost,
compared to this impoverished drawing.
Domain specificity of
the peaks and valleys
in Williams syndrome.
My colleagues and I over the years
have done a number of studies
trying to understand the brain features
that go along with that inability.
This is a posterior
back view of the brain.
We, and others now, have
found a structural anomaly.
This is not a lesion.
It would not be read as
such by any radiologist.
But this is a statistical finding,
a reduction in gray matter volume,
the gray matter of our brains,
right here early in the dorsal stream
that crosses where objects are in space.
We also found functional deficits
that emerged from this structural anomaly.
This has been a very well replicated
and reliable brain phenotype
for mapping gene effects.
That, of course, was our goal
in starting out these studies.
We have found, I don't have
time to talk about this today,
although perhaps we will in
the question and answer part,
but we found this to be linked
to one particular gene in
the Williams syndrome region,
the LIMK1 gene.
I'd like to turn to the
Williams syndrome profile now
because this is, in many ways,
the most immediately apparent
and captivating aspect
of folks with this syndrome.
They are highly and overly social,
they are empathic, outgoing, loquacious,
charming, unusually friendly,
even with strangers,
however, they're anxious in
some non-social situations.
Never social, non-social.
Increased sociability, increased
number of social contacts,
increased empathy that can
be measured experimentally.
They don't observe social
distance unless they're taught to.
They're socially fearless even in infancy,
but there is this strong
increase in non-social anxiety.
My colleagues and I have also
searched for brain features
underlying this aspect
of Williams syndrome
and we've become very interested
in an area called the insula
and convinced that it's important.
This is an area of the brain
that integrates cognitive,
affective, and social information.
It plays a crucial role in empathy,
in interoception,
thinking about ourselves,
and in social functions.
It's a great candidate.
We have found that both
the structural size
and the function of
this region of the brain
predicts the degree to
which this Williams syndrome
personality profile is expressed
in individual patients.
We've replicated this in a
large number of children now.
We have linked this to a general
transcription factor gene
that is in the Williams syndrome region.
I'd like to turn now to talk to you
about children with duplications.
These folks have three copies
of these relevant genes.
They provide a remarkable opportunity
and are extraordinarily interesting also.
People with the deletion
were described first
about a decade ago by my colleague
Carolyn Mervis and others
and you can see right away
that people with the duplication
have similar facial features,
as do those with with Williams syndrome,
but they're quite different.
They differ in other very
important and interesting ways.
Williams syndrome, as I've told you,
has a weakness in spatial skills,
whereas there's a relative
strength in spatial skills
in the duplication.
You can see this in examples
from two of our children
patients, child patients.
This is a 12 1/2 year old
with Williams syndrome
drawing a bike, a little impoverished.
This is a 10-year-old with
a duplication drawing a bike
and you can clearly see the
contrast in the level of detail
and spatial integration in this image.
Folks with Williams syndrome
have a strength in expressive language.
They're very personable and
good language relative to IQ.
People with the duplication
have a marked speech and language delay,
and this is often why
they come to the attention
of clinicians.
So a contrast there.
People with Williams syndrome
are excessively social.
However, people with the duplication
have problematic and
reduced social function
and, in fact, there was
a very influential paper
from UCSF showing that the duplication
of Williams syndrome genes is formally
and statistically associated
with a diagnosis of autism.
We've actually shown this experimentally
using a personality questionnaire
in which we found a factor,
a sociability factor,
comprised of cheerfulness, gregariousness,
people-orientedness,
visibility, affectionateness,
and responsivity that
had a step-wise function
according to the number of genes.
One copy in Williams syndrome,
here's their sociability score.
Two copies in typically
developing children, around zero.
And three, in the duplication syndrome.
We're using these values to
search for brain features
that may correlate with this gene dosage.
We believe that these brain features exist
and we will find them
and we actually have
some preliminary evidence
that I wanna share with you.
With regard to total brain volume
and relative cerebellar volume
we see opposite but step-wise functions.
One copy, two copies, three
copies of these genes.
What's interesting about this
is that the findings in
the duplication syndrome
are also evident in autism,
although there is some
controversy about this.
It will be such a privilege
to continue this work
and to continue to see these children
longitudinally over time,
which we're doing at the NIH right now.
Contrasting behaviors and brain features
associated with step-wise alterations
in these particular genes, in 7q11.23,
one copy of affected gene
in Williams syndrome,
two copies in the general population,
three in the duplication syndrome.
This is a very clear road
to uncovering neurogenetic mechanisms
and an extraordinary opportunity
to understand what makes
us who and what we are
and what biological mechanisms
confer our wonderful human variability.
It's an extraordinary syndrome
and a privilege to study it.
I'd like to take a moment
to thank our families
and our participants,
and I'd like to thank Doctor Bellugi
for her continuing inspiration
throughout my career,
and you for your attention.
(audience applauding)
- Why is a geneticist interested
in something like language,
something that we learn?
To answer this question,
I'm gonna hand over to somebody
who's much more eloquent than I am
and it's this fellow here, Charles Darwin.
About almost 150 years ago
he really summed up what's amazing
and remarkable about language.
He said, "Language is an
art like brewing or baking.
"It certainly is not a true instinct,
"for every language has to be learned.
"It differs widely from all ordinary arts,
"for man has an instinctive
tendency to speak,
"as we see in the babble
of our young children,
"while no child has an
instinctive tendency
"to brew, bake, or write."
This really beautifully captures
something strange about language.
Let's dig into this a little bit more.
By the time a child is
only a few years of age,
they've already assembled a vocabulary
of thousands of words.
They can assemble these words
into a potentially limitless
number of meaningful sentences
using grammatical rules.
These meaningful sentences
can relate not only to the present,
but also the past, the future,
even abstract concepts.
Then something that we
take completely for granted
but is really extraordinary
is the ability that a child learns
to take the thoughts that are
sitting inside their heads
and convert them into streams of sound
via the most incredible
feat of motor control
of the articulatory
functions moving the muscles
that control the face,
the jaw, the larynx,
in this rapid kind of
dance of motor function
that converts thoughts
into streams of sound.
And then another child's
ears can do an amazing thing
which is to kind of reverse engineer,
decode the stream of
sound, reverse engineer it,
figure out what the original thought was,
and come to their own conclusions.
All these different things
that happen in the
first few years of life.
A child can develop a suite of skills
without needing any kind of formal tuition
in a way that seems very almost magical.
It's a complicated set of different things
that go towards being able to become
a proficient speech and language user.
How do we explain this?
People have speculated
that there might be something
important in our genes.
Importantly here, this is
actually a great example,
a perfect example of interaction
between genes and environment.
Obviously as soon as
you think about the fact
that a child who grows
up in the Netherlands
surrounded by Dutch speakers
will learn to speak Dutch.
That same child growing up in Japan
surrounded by Japanese speakers
will learn to speak Japanese.
A child who is not exposed to language
will never become a language user.
There's this incredible interaction
between genetics and environment.
But there's something in the genes
that seems to predispose
us to soak up language
from the environment
around us in early life.
Not every child, unfortunately,
when exposed to language
becomes as proficient
as this young lady here, for example.
There are some kids who
are exposed to language
and have language-rich environments,
but they fail to become
proficient language users.
In some cases there might
be a reason for this,
like they have a physical
problem, they're deaf
or they have some kind of
general cognitive problem,
but in some cases there are
kids that fail to learn language
and it's a mystery and we don't know why.
It was noticed very early on
when people started studying
these kind of disorders
that these cases clustered in families.
If you have a relative with a problem
with development of speech and language,
that dramatically increases your risk.
This kind of familial clustering
could in fact relate to something
like shared environment,
for example, in the family.
We know from studies of twins
that actually there's a
very, very high heritability
for these kind of speech
and language disorders,
unexplained speech and language disorders.
We know this by looking at the concordance
and the rates of language
disorders in identical twins
as compared to non-identical twins.
There's been many, many studies
that robustly show this.
What I want to talk to you about
in the remainder of the talk
is the idea that we should
be able to go further
than just saying, "Well,
there's genes involved."
To actually being able to say,
"Can we take some people
"who have speech and language problems
"and figure out what the actual genes are,
"the particular genes that are important?"
One of the wonderful things
about being able to find
the genes that are involved
is that we can use these
as kind of windows,
molecular windows, into
the intermediate biology.
This is my favorite
slide that I always show
and everybody, I think,
has a version of this slide
if they work on genes
and brain and behavior.
There's this huge gap
between DNA and the outputs,
the behavioral outputs,
that we're interested in.
We're not so naive to ignore that gap,
but we think that we can use
the knowledge of the genetics
to actually fill in and
understand each different level
so we can understand that
many genes that we study
are important because
they code for proteins
and the proteins kind of all work together
as molecular and machinery in your cells
to do all the functions of your cells.
We know that genes and
proteins are important
for different properties of
the way that neurons develop.
For example, they might influence
the proliferation of neurons
in early development.
They might influence how neurons move,
migrate to the final
positions in the brain,
how those neurons
differentiate and extend out
kind of their axons to
connect up and wire up
with other neurons in the brain.
Then we might want to understand
how neuro circuits actually work.
One of the most fascinating things
about the interaction between
genes and neuro circuitry
is that your genes are
important for their functions
of your neuro circuits
even in your adult brain
because they help you to learn,
they help genes actively
working to strengthen and weaken
the links, the synapses,
the links between your
different brain cells
throughout life.
Of course, we have these
complex assemblages
of neuro circuits built by combination
of genes and experience
and it's those in the brain
that are doing these kind
of complex behaviors.
The idea here is that
if we can find something
at this end of the
spectrum, at the DNA level,
and we know that it's
linked this other end
to speech and language,
we can use that as a tool
for understanding all
these different levels.
There's interactions and
relationships between the levels.
This is a gross over simplification,
but it's a starting
point for thinking about
what I'm gonna talk about.
I'm gonna give you an example
where we've been able to identify a gene
that's important in speech
and language development.
The starting point for this study
was this family here, the KE family.
It's a three generation family,
now a four generation family.
In each of these generations
you can see these shaded individuals
are affected with a severe
speech and language disorder.
They're growing up together
with these unaffected
individuals who are non-shaded,
who are growing up together
with the kids who
develop a severe problem.
The severe problem is that
they have difficulties
learning to make those
coordinated sequences of speech.
They do actually become speech users,
but there's always a problem
and I'm gonna now play you an example,
hopefully, if this works,
from one of the adult
members of the KE family
from the second generation.
She's being asked by Kate Watkins,
a PhD student at the time,
she now leads a group in Oxford,
but at the time she was
a PhD student in London
with Faraneh Vargha-Khadem
studying this family,
and she asks the lady to repeat
different words five times.
She's going to ask them to
repeat the word catastrophe.
So listen to this.
- [Kate] Catastrophe.
- [Woman] Castas, cat-as-ophe, catas.
(grumbling)
- [Kate] Catastrophe.
(faint speaking)
(whimpering)
It's hard, isn't it?
- [Woman] It's a real tongue twister.
- She's having a great trouble
repeating the word catastrophe.
That's not a comment
on the political situation at the moment.
(audience laughing)
I promised I wouldn't be political.
Anyway.
This trait that she has,
it's called childhood apraxia of speech.
But actually, as you can hear,
it persists into adulthood.
And even despite some
intensive speech therapy,
people still suffer from these problems.
The problem is that they have problems
stringing together certain
sequences of sound.
The problems gets worse as
the utterances get longer
and as they become more complex.
This is shown, this is a study
that Kate Watkins carried out
on the KE family where
they're being asked to repeat
either simple or complex nonsense words.
These are nonsense words like
contrapanist and puplisterog,
words that now I practice every
day in front of the mirror
so I'm very good at them.
These people have never
encountered the words
and they try to repeat them back
and they have difficulty doing so.
What you can see on these graphs
is these are unaffected
members of the KE family,
these are affected
and this third line is
actually adults with brokers
and other kinds of aphasias,
brain damage that yields
problems with speech access.
Here, as you can see,
the material that gives
them the most difficulty
is when they have to
repeat these nonsense words
that are really long and complex.
It's not that they can't
say certain sounds,
it's that they have particular problems
with stringing them
together in the right way.
Something to do with the way
that the brain is programming sequences
of mouth and face movements during speech.
They also have lots of other problems
with all sorts of aspects of language.
They have deficits not
just in spoken language,
but also if you ask them to
write linguistic items, as well.
Their impairment's not just in expression,
but also in reception of language.
There are tests of grammar
comprehension and production
that they do worse on than
unaffected individuals.
This is not a kind of general
intellectual disability.
They don't all have a kind of IQ
that's in the intellectual
disability range.
But this family is not the
brightest family in the world.
There are some unaffected
individuals in the family
who have low non-verbal IQ,
and there are affected individuals
who have normal non-verbal IQ
and severe speech and language problems.
It doesn't seem like that
the non-verbal problems
that some of the family
members suffer from,
it doesn't seem like they're a
core feature of the disorder.
If you look at patterns of
non-verbal and verbal cognition,
different kinds of subtests,
you find that they have deficits
that are much more severe
in the verbal range,
which is what you would expect
for a speech and language disorder.
Working in the lab with Tony
Monaco in the late 1990s,
we started screening
the DNA from this family
and we pinpointed a linked
region on chromosome seven.
This was actually a different region
from the region that
you've just heard about
in the Williams syndrome talk.
Eventually we zoomed in and
spotted a single tiny change,
one letter of DNA, one base of DNA,
which normally in every
unaffected person in this family
and in every one of you
I can guarantee, was a g.
In the affected members of the family,
they have two copies of every gene.
Once copy had the g, one copy was normal,
but one copy has an a instead of a g.
This was private mutation
that had occurred
in the grandma of that family
and then been passed on to
half of the affected members
and the unaffected members
did not receive this variant.
This was in a gene called FOXP2.
We could already say something
about what the gene was.
It's a gene that regulates other genes,
I'll tell you about that in a minute.
All these genes,
genes like FOXP2,
they have something called
a forkhead box domain.
They make a protein that
has this special domain here
that I'm showing you
and it consists of these
three helices here,
one, two, and three, and
these big loops here.
The KE family have this mutation
that changes one of the amino acids
in the protein that they built for FOXP2
and it's this amino acid here.
It stops the protein from
doing its job properly.
It stops the protein from binding to DNA.
Since finding this
mutation in the KE family,
we and others have found
a bunch of other different
mutations in FOXP2
in different cases around the world.
This just shows you a
picture from a later study
showing about eight or
nine different mutations
that are being found,
disturbing different
letters of the FOXP2 gene.
In each case, they damage
one copy of the FOXP2 gene,
but leave another copy of
the FOXP2 gene in tact.
These people have kind
of a insufficient amount
of FOXP2 protein that they're making
and they have speech and
language problems sometimes,
other problems in addition,
but the kind of most common feature
across all these patients is
speech and language disorder.
We've been able to take
the different mutations
that disrupt FOXP2 and
look at them in the lab.
We can grow cells in the lab
and label FOXP2 in green.
Here is the nucleus of cells.
Here is normal FOXP2 being expressed
in the nucleus of these cells,
which is where it likes to be.
Here are some examples of mutations
where the protein can no
longer get into the nucleus.
And we do other isos that show
that FOXP2 is not working
properly in these cells.
The idea then is that you can use FOXP2
to study all these intermediate levels
from DNA to speech and language.
I refer you to these papers
to find out more about it.
I'm just gonna give you
a couple of examples
because I'm running out of time
of the kinds of things that
we've been studying with FOXP2.
FOXP2 is a regulatory gene
that switches on and off other genes
and this is how it works.
It gets transcribed into messenger RNA.
This messenger RNA is used as a template
to build a protein also called FOXP2.
This FOXP2 protein finds target genes
and it binds to the promoters,
the regulatory regions of
the front of each gene,
and it could either activate them
or it could repress them,
it could silence them.
We think that a lot of the time
what FOXP2 is doing is
to silence these genes.
But it can also act as an activator.
It seems to do this
like a kind of genetic
demonstrate if you like.
It's not all or nothing.
We can then have a look,
we know that we have this gene,
can we ask what are the other
elements of this FOXP2 network
that it belongs to.
We might ask what are the things
that bind to the FOXP2 gene
to switch it on.
What are the things signaling processes
that interact with FOXP2
to modulate its function?
What are the other
factors that bind FOXP2?
What are the downstream targets
that it's switching on and off?
We've identified quite
a few downstream targets
and many people have been
working on this over the years.
What's interesting is that many of targets
that FOXP2 regulates are
known to be important
for neuro development
because when they go wrong,
they cause neuro developmental disorders
like autism, schizophrenia,
epilepsy, and so on.
We've identified pathways like SUMOylation
that modulate the way that
FOXP2 works in the cell.
And also other proteins like
TBR1 that interact with FOXP2
and are also implicated in
neuro developmental syndromes.
We can go further to ask what
is the influence to FOXP2
on the neuronal properties.
One of the neuronal properties
that FOXP2 pairs to influence
is the outgrowth of neurites from cells.
These are the things from neurons.
These are the things that
will eventually connect
and become axons and dendrites
and connect up with other neurons.
When FOXP2 is lost, it can
lead to shorter neurites
with reduced branching.
You might ask then, if
FOXP2's so important
for things like the outgrowth of neurites,
when we have a loss of FOXP2,
why don't we have a global problem
with the whole of our brains?
The reason for this is that FOXP2
is not actually switched on
itself all over the brain.
It's switched on in
certain subsets of cells.
This is if I took your brain,
which I promise I won't
do, and I slice it in half,
you can see this is a
kind of cross section.
FOXP2 is expressed in the
deepest layers of the cortex,
especially in motor regions,
it's expressed in layer
six and layer five.
It's also expressed in the basal ganglia
in the striatum and the caudate, putamen,
the thalamus, and in the cerebellum
it's expressed in a
very specific cell type
called the Purkinje cells.
What a lot of these circuits do,
the cortico, basal ganglia,
and cortico cerebellar circuits
is they're important for you
to do motor skill learning,
to learn to make motor sequences.
Since FOXP2 is not a new human gene,
it's actually present in
all sorts of other organisms
in evolutionary history,
we can study what FOXP2 does
say by looking at it in a mouse.
When we take a mouse, we can
study the way that neurons,
these neurons that express FOXP2,
the way they fire during
motor skill learning.
We can thus kind of get
insights into what's happening.
We found that in these different
places in the striatum,
also in Purkinje cells in the cerebellum,
that the firing of the neurons
during motor skill learning
and motor skill tasks is different
from when FOXP2 is mutated
from unaffected animals.
I'm gonna finish there by just summing up.
FOXP2 at the extremes.
What does this tell us
about speech and language development?
Heterozygous mutations in FOXP2
cause a rare severe speech and
language disorder in humans.
It's a regulatory gene, so its
targets and its interactors
give us entry points into neural pathways.
It's not a gene for speech,
because as I've told you
versions of FOXP2 are active in the brains
of many different vertebrate species.
The nice thing there
is that we can actually
study what FOXP2 does
in these other places,
in these other species.
By studying humans, mice,
and even song birds,
which I didn't have time to talk about,
we can uncover the roles of the gene
in these kind of circuits
like cortico-basal ganglia
and cerebellar circuitry that
are known to be important
for complex motor functions.
The curious question would be
we know that when FOXP2's damaged
it impairs your speech motor skills.
It'd be interesting to see
whether at the other end of the spectrum,
for example in people who are
really good at beat boxing,
or rapping, maybe they have
an interesting variance of FOXP2.
The last thing I'd like to say
is that the fact that FOXP2's
been around for a long time
in evolutionary history
and has been doing important
things in the brain
means that whatever it's doing
in speech and language in humans
is not novel and de novo,
but it's built on ancient stuff.
I think this suggests to us
that our unique capacity for
acquiring spoken language
is built on systems that
are evolutionarily ancient.
There I will stop.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
(bright music)